the man accused of driving into a large
crowd in New York's Times Square is now
charged with second degree murder
Richard Rojas is also facing five counts
of aggravated vehicular homicide and 20
counts of attempted murder the Bronx man
smashed into the dizzy area just before
noon yesterday killing a teenager police
said he was going south on 7th Avenue
then made an abrupt u-turn and jumped a
curb he drove down the sidewalk for
three blocks Tamika Duncan is near where
his car finally came to a stop drink a
good morning good morning you can see
that car has been removed you know one
eyewitness said this car was barreling
down the sidewalk like a bowling ball
striking several people in its path it
only came to a stop because of these
steel barricades behind me some of the
video we're about to show you is graphic
part of the rampage was captured on
surveillance video you can see the red
Honda quickly make a u-turn and take off
down the sidewalk after mowing down 23
people the car then crashed into
barricades meant to stop runaway
vehicles
he's clearly dead it was just speeding
as fast as ELISA L ceman an 18 year old
girl visiting from Michigan was killed
her 13 year old sister was also injured
but survived the alleged driver Richard
Rojas tried to flee the scene bystanders
helped police capture him the traffic
agent at the time say get him he got
away from three of them and I tackled
him so far investigators do not believe
it was an act of terrorism that being
said we are reinforcing key locations
around the city with our anti-terror
units of the NYPD
Rojas a US citizen has had prior run-ins
with police earlier this month he was
arrested for menacing in 2008 he was
arrested in Queens for drinking and
driving and also in 2015 he was arrested
in Manhattan for drinking and driving
Rojas served in the US Navy from
September 2011 to May 2014 in 2013 he
spent two months in a Navy prison after
being court-martialed police sources
tell CBS this morning that Rojas said he
wanted to die that he heard voices and
that he did it for God he did pass a
breathalyzer test but police sources
also tell us that preliminary tests show
he had PCP and marijuana in his system
thank you very much jurika